you have to hit shows on the air - yeah
the salsa you have the Goldberg
Solberg's and you have Curb Your
Enthusiasm no hit show now which one of
those do you want to promote promote one
thing hold on a second here mister I
don't want to promote either neither
they're both so successful they don't
need promoting you know what I want to
promote I want to promote my favorite
comedian his name is John Mulaney lady
is hosting Saturday Night Live this
Saturday so watch John Mulaney do
Saturday Night Live you can't catch me
all the time yes yes he's the best comic
out there right by far by hand
today also add he has a new Netflix
special that comes out on May 1st so I'm
here tonight really to promote John
Mulaney that's very nice of you but my
question is how does any of that help me
by the way John Mulaney becomes more
successful when it comes on your show it
creates excitement I love John I think
John's a genius I saw his show downtown
he did his show in about two months ago
and it was one of the funnier qulet to
our Largo but still amazing us talking
about him again doesn't help me well
you've got to stop thinking about
yourself no there was only some drug
that would take my mind off myself
would have brought some with me yeah oh
my god I forgot to bring my pen I shut
up yeah you wouldn't be able to do the
rest of the show yeah you know you don't
need that yeah I can't do this show when
I'm acting all crazy and everything all
right John Mulaney we're gonna host this
we're in at Hostos we're gonna we're
gonna get this out there saying jumble
any around right now is hosting CERN out
live this weekend so we're gonna both
plug John Mulaney I don't know let me
watch it
and his new Netflix special debuts May
1st you owe us big time
[Applause]
you